of the three tiers in relation to the
response level alert serious and
emergency the level had been raised to
serious now today I'd like to announce
that we are going to escalate it to the
highest level that is emergency Adrian
Brown is live for us in Hong Kong is
looking at the latest developments there
so let's start with the latest statement
what does that mean for the territory
now to be at an emergency level well she
is going to set up not just one but also
for task force to look at different ways
of trying to you know contain this
crisis she's also saying that all main
and people can all citizens coming from
from mainland China whether by road rail
sea air will have to sign health
declaration forms on their arrival but
of course that is dependent on people's
honesty declaring where they've really
been in China had they been to Wuhan a
lot of people are saying this is
something that she should have done in
fact several weeks ago when this scale
of this crisis started to become
apparent but she's done that now she's
also going to extend the current Lunar
New Year school holidays until February
the 17th so yes I think it's a final
acknowledgement today that Hong Kong
does now regard this as a crisis she has
confirmed what many people have
suspected all along that this thing is
getting much more serious the mood in
Hong Kong is is subdued it's flat there
is no panic that has to be stressed but
there is a deepening sense of unease
about where we are now heading we've
been hearing also today from one of Hong
Kong's leading microbiologist the reason
why he's important is because he played
a leading role in the efforts to try to
contain the spread of the SARS virus 17
years ago and he says that this current
virus has an attack rate of 83% which
sounds you know quite scary and he's
also suggesting that everyone going out
in public now in Hong Kong should wear a
face mask many more people wearing face
masks than this time yesterday it has to
be said and he's also
the government to do what it's now done
which is to you know extend the leave
for students and pupils at schools and
universities in Hong Kong this of course
is is really a very testing time for
President Xi Jingping because he really
is under pressure on so many fronts
right now the elections in Taiwan didn't
go the way he wanted them to also you
know in his trade negotiations with the
United States he's had to make very
important concessions and of course the
protests here in Hong Kong are still
going on eight months on and now he's
having to convince at times what seems
to be quite a skeptical public in China
that his his government is capable of
trying to contain this spreading virus
but of course because of the extensive
censorship you have in China that tends
to breed skepticism at times like this
and how easy is it right now to
implement screening given that it's
difficult to detect the virus right long
incubation periods not always very
obvious signs no you're absolutely right
and the microbiologist I was referring
to earlier on made this same point today
he said that you know someone arriving
from the mainland on a Friday will seem
perfectly healthy and not develop any
symptoms until you know three or four
days later this virus has you know a
pretty long incubation period so people
who may be sick don't show signs of
illness until several days later that is
the big worry about this virus something
similar happened with SARS but this
particular virus seems to be a lot more
deceptive the problem for Hong Kong sámi
is the government can control some
things but it can't control geography
Hong Kong borders China and of course
there are myriad ways for mainland
people to enter Hong Kong and of course
some of those people coming into Hong
Kong have come from Wuhan via other
cities like Shenzhen or Guangzhou just
across the border or I will leave it
there for now thanks so much Adrian
Brown